want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only dr joe dispenza enjoy
is no longer about pleasure or having a
car it's something that you're
cultivating within you so then imagine
we have research to show and this is
such a this is such a duality
that when you start seeing the brain
start synchronizing getting coherent the
front of the brain and the back of the
brain that two hemispheres coming
together and you we can say to
scientists that come and study our work
oh watch this ed's gonna pop what do you
mean just watch this is going to be good
and all of a sudden you see this brain
going into this kind of psychic union
the heart blows wide open you see
coherence going on and you look around
at that person and there's tears running
down their face
imagine feeling so whole
that it's impossible to want i mean how
can you want when you're whole because
you feel like you already have it now
when you reach that point
that's when the magic happens because
now you are worthy to receive
and the universe only gives us what we
think we're worthy of receiving share
this with them yeah i think you know for
me i mean
um
i'm curious and i'm a pragmatist i mean
if you tell me something all i want to
know is how i'm going to use it in my
life yes and i'm not in the dinner
conversation because nobody changes from
that you know i mean i'm a doer and i
want to be around doers and and this is
why you and i connect so well i think
and i yeah obviously and and and and uh
you you create a group of people
that are passionate about transformation
and they've they've done some of the
work when we were doing our four day
four and a half day uh advanced
workshops right around the end of the
event i was seeing people starting to
notice seeing some really great
transformations and i thought this is
the pop yeah it's a pop yeah big pops
yeah and we were like we had to send
them home
and i was like oh god man if i could
just have them for a week
so we created these week-long events
where people retreat from their lives
and
they remove the constant stimulation in
their external environment that reminds
them of who they think they are as a
personality yes they separate themselves
from the people they know and the places
they go and the things that they do at a
certain amount of time in their routine
mundane life so we'll bridge a little
quantum physics with a little
neuroscience little neuro endocrinology
a little epigenetics
psychoneuroimmunology those are all
sciences about possibility and i now
know that if you can give people sound
scientific information and you know
for me that's the language
and then if they can turn to the person
next to them and explain it you're not
going to get off the hook
if you can't explain it it's not wired
in your brain but if you can build a
model and explain it you're installing
the neurological hardware in your brain
in preparation for the experience so the
more you understand what you're doing
and why
how it gets easier because you can
assign meaning to it so then if i can
set up the conditions in the environment
and give them the proper instructions
and push the envelope a little bit yeah
and people who get their behaviors to
match their intentions and their actions
equal to their thoughts they get their
mind and body working together
they're going to have a new experience
and the experience then is not only
going to enrich the philosophical
circuits in their brain because
experience does that but it's going to
produce an emotion so they're going to
start feeling more unlimited
how
bad
does it have to get i mean to what
denominator
to what lowest level do you have to
reach
before people really make up their mind
to change my message is why wait i mean
when you're feeling so altered
emotionally you feel so bad that's the
moment you could actually see yourself
for the first time because you're you're
not answering your cell phone you're not
responding to all your texts you're not
watching tv you're not going out to
dinners you're not calling people back
you're something's altered in you and
you're starting to become self-aware
right
so then
people wait to that lowest moment where
they can start to see themselves through
the eyes of somebody else well
if you're waking up every day and you're
combining a clear intention with an
elevated emotion and you're changing
your emotional state to be elevated
you could still see the old self from an
elevated point of view and be state
conscious then from a limited point of
view and that's what i want for people
like let's go i mean what do you got to
lose what people are going to start
wondering like did you change your
medication
what's up with that guy something's
different about him you're not
predictable any longer right then we say
to our
our community you know when you're
changing you just stop talking about it
you're just too busy being it
something's happening you know and
that's
the repetition of getting a few days in
a row
of that really well i always say
god if you had a great meditation you
wake up feeling better
at the end of that meditation than when
you started and you do that the next day
and then the next day you're gonna start
feeling better all the time and that
your body is gonna start feeling better
and everything is going to start feeling
better and you're going to start feeling
better about life so
you ask the person why are you so
unhappy why are you so frustrated why
are you so resentful the moment you ask
that their brain is going to associate
that emotion to a past event to a memory
to a memory
that's because they have nothing to look
forward to in their future so if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it just means to me that you're
more in love with your past
than you are with the future so how do
you teach people to believe in a future
that they can't see or experience with
their senses yet
but they've thought about enough times
in their mind that their brain is
literally changed to look like the event
has already occurred the latest research
in neuroscience says that's absolutely
possible we know that and how do you
teach a person
to select a new possibility in their
future and begin to emotionally embrace
that future before it's made manifest to
such a degree that their body as their
unconscious mind is believing it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and they're signaling new
genes in new ways ahead of the
environment
now to their body begins to change to
look like the event has already occurred
we've proven that that's possible now
think about this so the more you think
about your desired future the joy
the gratitude the
uh
the feelings you want to have that are
more positive the more you think about
it as it's as a future thing happening
the more your body shifts now
exactly so your body is believing it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment now think about this the
stronger the emotion you feel from some
condition in your life the more altered
you feel inside of you the more you
narrow your focus on the cause and the
brain freezes an image and takes a
snapshot and that memory now is embossed
in the brain it's branded in there so
then people think neurologically within
the circuits of those past experiences
and they feel chemically within the
boundaries of those emotions and the
stronger the betrayal the stronger the
trauma
the more the body's living in the past
right so then so how to reverse that so
now
if you truly got passionate about a
future we've all done this you get a
wild idea in your mind and you start
holding on to that vision and you're
preoccupied with it all of a sudden the
thought in your mind becomes the
experience and you start feeling the the
energy of the future now the stronger
the emotion you feel from that vision
the more you're going to pay attention
to the picture in your mind and now
you're remembering your future and vice
versa the stronger you pay attention to
the feeling of the past pain you're
going to create the pain in this moment
exactly
so then so it requires a coherent brain
and we now know that there's a formula
for that and we've got beautiful
research to show that people can do it
they just have to practice and it
requires a coherent heart because
resentment frustration in patience
creates a very incoherent heart yeah and
when that heart becomes incoherent you
stop trusting yourself there's no energy
you stop trusting in your future
so then if there's physical evidence in
your brain and body
physical evidence to look like the event
has already occurred it's quite possible
you'll be thinking neurologically within
the circuits of your future and you'll
begin to feel chemically within the
boundaries of that emotion of your
future and how you think and how you
feel is your state of being
and now your state of being is living in
the future instead of the past now
the moment you disconnect from the
emotion of your future because traffic
or some co-worker or your ex or whatever
people come up with
now you're back to the energy of your
past and now you're gonna start looking
for it analyzing why hasn't it happened
well if you're feeling the emotion of
your future why would you look for it
because you would feel like it already
happened and that is the place where the
magic happens so then you can't just do
this
get up and then return back to your old
state of being
you got to maintain that modified
statement
well of course of course i mean we all
take blows in our lives yeah and and we
all react emotionally but the question
is
how long are you going to reach right
right so then
if you can't mediate and regulate your
emotional reactions and those emotions
linger for days that's years for some
people mood and then months temperament
years personality trait so then the
person's personality is literally based
on the past but they don't know that
because they're doing it over and over
again it becomes a subconscious program
so now
if it requires a coherent brain and a
coherent heart then we have to train
people how to self-regulate the person's
doing the vision board and they're
saying when i get my new car i get my
new house i get my new relationship
then i'm gonna feel so great now that
well then they're back to the program
waiting for it to happen
for them to feel the emotion they're
they're believing their outer world has
to change in order for them to feel
better there's there's no
effect of drawing the experience to you
with that way
so
the person has to use those tools
to get them into the emotional state
for them to feel like it's already
happened now think about this
if you get up from a creative process
and you feel grateful
you feel a love for life you feel a joy
for existence
you feel a passion
uh to
for the moment uh
you will not be looking for your future
because you'll feel like it's already
happened
it's the moment that we start feeling
those self-limiting emotions that we
feel separation and then we start
looking for it again well then if you're
waiting you're not creating you're
you're in separation again so then yeah
so then
whatever it takes for you to move into a
state of being and what is a state of
being
thoughts are the vocabulary of the brain
feelings are the vocabulary of your body
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being so then if you wake
up in the morning and you
come come back to your senses with a
clean slate and you say i don't feel
anything you say well let me start
thinking about all the problems in my
life well all those problems are
connected to different people or
different objects of things at different
times and places the moment you remember
your problems a memory is a record of
the past you're thinking in the past
every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them so all of a
sudden you start feeling unhappy you
start feeling bitter you start feeling
frustrated so now your body's in the
past so then most people then
create a state of being that's connected
to their past and if they're in the
familiar past
then they are going to crave the
predictable future and they're going to
fall back into routine
so then
we want people then to get very clear on
that vision of their future however they
do it and begin to combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion and
the stronger the emotion they feel
from the vision they're creating the
more altered they feel inside of them
the more they're going to pay attention
to the pictures in their mind and now
they're remembering their future and
biologically it's exactly the same as
remembering your past in fact if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it means you're making your past
more real than your future you're
falling in love with your past you're
more in love with your past than you are
with your future that you're believing
in your past more than you're believing
in your future when you get to that
moment
where you have that feeling
that's your compass
because that feeling is going to drive
your behaviors it's going to drive more
of those thoughts and when you feel that
feeling and it's visceral
no person
no thing no experience will stand in the
way between you and that vision and and
you will be initiated in by the universe
into wealth you will be initiated into
health you'll be initiated into freedom
those people
all those people that have healed
themselves of all those different health
conditions
they are so humble
and so happy and they feel so great that
they would never trade this feeling
because of what you thought of them they
they've left that program behind a long
time ago they actually don't care how
you think of them they actually are so
happy with themselves
that they're no longer dependent on
anything outside of them now i think
that's a really important moment because
that's the moment we give people
permission in our lives to do the same
right and i think that more and more
people are beginning to figure that out
one of the things about the global
pandemic that i said to my staff and to
my family the moment i heard how the
circumstances in the world changed i
just said i refuse to be a victim
to these circumstances so a victim
consciousness is when
we allow something in our outer
environment to control the way we feel
and think so i say to you jay why are
you so upset today and you said oh it's
because of this person or circumstance
what you're really saying is something
in my outer environment some person or
some condition is controlling the way i
think and feel and that's not the truth
that's just a response right
so anything that controls our thoughts
and feelings causes us to be victim to
those things and the stronger the
emotion we feel to some circumstance in
our life the more we pay attention to it
and where we place our attention is
where we place our energy so we're
giving our life force we're giving our
power away to that circumstance and so i
just made up my mind that
it was a great opportunity to get into
the cocoon a habit is a redundant set of
automatic unconscious thoughts behaviors
and emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person
running through the same routine every
single day is on autopilot and their
body's now dragging them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists is the sweet spot of
the generous present moment that is when
the body and mind are free from those
conditions
so along with those emotions that
influence the same thoughts
people start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled they start
getting more afraid more anxious more
depressed and now the body is literally
being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency you tap all the body's
resources for some threat whether it's
real or imagined
and so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool
but the arousal that's created from
those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion
and in a sense they become addicted to
the life they don't even like
and this is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay i'm not
going to say i can't i'm not going to
judge another person i'm not going to
blame i'm not going to complain i'm not
going to make excuses i'm not going to
be a victim i'm not going to talk trash
about anybody i'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
then the body's saying you're out of
schedule you normally at eight in the
morning you're getting traffic and
you're angry then at 11 o'clock you
check your emails and you're really
judgmental and frustrated the body's
saying well you've been doing this for
the last 20 years you're just going to
stop today so now the body which has
been conditioned emotionally to be the
mind wants to return back to its
familiar territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on
this is a good time to judge that come
on this is a good time to suffer it's
your ex's fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh
you know it's the weather what the news
whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those pharmacy of
chemicals
and so that's when the person makes the
same choice
does the same thing
creates the same experience just for
that familiar feeling okay i'll complain
just so i can feel suffering then
they'd rather
be unhappy
than step into the unknown i think that
emotions are energy in motion
and so let's just say that um
we share the same experiences okay i
don't we're friends and we share the
same experience you're from london i've
been to london my daughter lives in
london and we have hey you do this i do
that you did the you know you own this i
own that you know so what we do is we
actually look to see when we meet people
if we're matching neurologically if
we're matching emotionally so if we
share the same experiences we share the
same emotions and if we share the same
emotions we can relate to one another so
this is where it gets sticky so then the
moment you start saying ah
that person did that to you once yeah
that person i had a similar experience
to that person that to me now
now
we open the door like i'm gonna use you
to reaffirm
my
attachment to that emotion
and let's just work it up so that you
can suffer and i can suffer and then we
can have a conversation and literally
we're sharing the same energy and if
we're sharing the same energy we're
sharing the same information and we're
bound by an invisible field
of energy that keeps us connected yes so
then what does it take to break that
energetic field and energy that's
greater than the energy that's holding
it together that's how you separate
atoms that become a molecule you they're
they're bound by an invisible field of
energy that's keeping them connected so
you got to use a greater energy than the
energy that's holding them together to
separate them well
in order for you to change then you
can't have energy without awareness or
consciousness you've got to go to a
greater level of consciousness and
change your energy and nobody changes
jay until they change their energy when
they change their energy they changed
their life so then you may say well this
person you know i i use this person and
i use my enemy to reaffirm my addiction
to hatred i use my co-worker to reaffirm
my addiction to judgment i use my ex to
reaffirm my
addiction to resentment that we have
these different people in our lives that
we need to remind us of who we think we
are the enemy dies and you find another
one
you know you know your co-worker uh
leaves and you start judging another one
it's just
it's not any it's not that so then
when there's no longer a vibrational
match
when you start doing the work there's no
longer a vibrational match with you and
your past present reality that that
person or that condition any longer
that person or condition is going to
spiral away because you're no longer
you're no longer in need of that so then
our life begins to change when we change
our energy and we begin to take our
power back that's essential for us to
begin to create with now some people
can't handle that because
they're not conscious that they're doing
it so they'll be working on their vision
of the future
and yet they'll spend two hours
lowering their energy back into
victimization or suffering and they want
to know why their future isn't happening
well
there's an unconscious program let's go
after that and once you start going
after that
now all of a sudden your life starts to
change again so you can't say it doesn't
work
on some level we don't work and if
you're really invested in this
the question is what is it about me
where am i directing my attention or my
energy who am i using to reaffirm some
conditioning that i need to remember as
my old self so then when you stop
reacting to the person or the person is
now complaining to you and you're not
complaining back
it's going to be an uncomfortable moment
because
you're all of a sudden seeing a part of
you
you used to be that you no longer are
and you have to be willing
to not go there and over time that
person will thank you and they'll say i
didn't even know that i was complaining
that much and
by changing yourself you help others you
ought to stay conscious
and not go unconscious and it turns out
that 95
of the time we're unconscious so if
you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so
the thoughts that they're thinking
are slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
i can't it's too hard my life will never
change it's someone else's fault those
thoughts have consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts becomes
aware of how they speak and how they act
and they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
there are
when you when you're distracted by your
environment and you got your cell phone
and your tweeting and your
instagramming and facebook and whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay close your eyes
sit in the in the silence of any
external stimulation remove the
environment sit your body down like an
animal body is the animal tell it to
stay i'm going to feed you
you can check your cell phone you can
shower you can have your coffee but when
i say
and so then here comes the challenge
right so and and then if you say then
you're not going to live in the familiar
future a familiar past or predictable
future you're not going to think about
how long you've been meditating what you
got to do you you labor
uh for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it
but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and
check your cell phone or have a cup of
coffee and you become aware that it's on
autopilot and wants to do that and you
say
come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now that's
greater than the program and if the
person
wants to just get angry while they're
sitting there there's an arousal and
they notice the body is amping up and
revving up and they settle it back down
now they're telling the body it's no
longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this
and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because david
is fighting goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner or later the body is trained to a
new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from the body as
energy so the person who has the strong
emotion to some circumstance in their
life
and they're
they're working and lowering the volume
of that emotion the more they lower the
volume of that emotion the more they're
going to take their attention off that
person and problem and they're going to
take their power back there's going to
be a break
in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming
overcoming
overcoming overcoming until we become
somebody else and when that occurs and
the person starts thinking differently
and they start acting differently
and they start feeling differently
they're a new personality and they they
start seeing those synchronicities and
serendipity turns out we've done an
experiment just 10 minutes a day
three times a day with 120 people
trading resentment frustration fear for
gratitude appreciation and thankfulness
measuring their immune response
the the chemical immunoglobulin a your
primary defense against bacteria and
viruses the best flu shot you'll ever
get lives innately within you turns out
when you're frustrated when you're
impatient when you're fearful the immune
system dials down because you're an
emergency it's not it's all your energy
is going for some threat in your outer
world there's no energy in your inner
world for growth and repair but how do
you turn that around so then as people
begin to open their heart
can that chemical begin
to to
elevate
four days
50
change in the 120 people their their iga
levels went up 50 in four days that's
your body's immune system is now
upregulating genes that are making
proteins and immunoglobulins and
antibodies that you don't need a flu
shot in other words your interstate is
greater than your outer world so then
just by doing that we now know that your
immune system is going to get stronger
by the same means
take 120 people or 50 people and measure
7500 gene regulations okay
in four days two genes that suppress
cancer growth and tumors are activated
and up regulated the genes that
stimulate stem cells that go to damaged
tissues and repair them up regulate them
the gene for oxidative balance is
upregulated anti-cancer anti-aging
anti-heart disease anti-stroke
anti-neurodegenerative anti-inflammatory
antimicrobial just your body's naturally
doing this
the gene for neurogenesis the growth of
new neurons in response to novel
experiences and learning this is four
days the gene switches on
uh the gene for more balance in the
pituitary and the pancreas the gene for
the microtubules of the cells the the
little little fibers that respond to
energy and frequency so in four days we
now know that you can change your
genetic destiny
if you just practice the inner work if
you think about this your senses plug
you into your external environment
everything you're seeing or smelling or
tasting or feeling or hearing all of
your five senses are affecting your
brain
so if you're waking up in the morning
and you're going through the same
routine behaviors as you did the day
before
and you're not in the process of being
defined by a vision of the future
then you're for the most part left with
the old hardware in your brain from the
past as a matter of fact your brain is
organized to reflect everything you know
from the past
so as people wake up and they begin to
pay attention to their body they start
to look around in their environment they
start to do typical things
it's the external environment that's
turning on different circuits in their
brain causing them to think equal to
their environment
and if you have the idea that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny as long as you're thinking equal
to your environment you keep creating
the same reality over and over again
so to change is to think greater than
your environment to think greater than
the circumstances in your world to think
greater than the conditions in your life
and i think every great person in
history understood this they were
defined by a vision that was much bigger
than that i think one of the challenges
i think many people have is really the
discernment of information
it's really difficult to know what's the
truth anymore just because information
is so accessible and i used to say that
in an age of information ignorance is a
choice and and now we have to confront a
whole nother level and that is the
information that we're getting uh is it
is it actually supporting us or is it
something that really is an incentive to
to cause us to make choices so um for me
i think the biggest challenge has been
just really an awakening to
what kind of information i want to
expose myself to and i think it's now
more than ever a challenge for a lot of
people in the world overcoming the old
self
allows us to become somebody else and
there is that period of transition yeah
i call it the void where there's just
not a lot happening
and you just got to be able to keep
going and continuously get to the end of
your belief where most people stop i
just had a fabulous conversation with
someone
this weekend
broke through to the other side
and now there's so much magic happening
around this person
but she's worthy now
to receive it and that's that
that is the key because the universe
only gives us what we think we're worthy
of receiving so we gotta become
initiated into this and understand it
thousands of years of programming that
says that we have to change things uh
matter to matter you know in
three-dimensional reality and it will
take time but
to begin to connect to that resource
called the quantum field and create from
the field instead of from matter
there's a lot of unlearning that has to
go on i think this is a time in history
where it's not enough to know there's a
time in history to know how and if you
rewind the tape 10 years ago you know
information was the thing that
stimulated thought stimulated new ideas
and and as we learn new things we make
new connections in our brains so
as we begin to add new stitches into
that three-dimensional tapestry in our
mind
we're beginning to cause our mind to
function in new ways but the key then
is to apply it to personalize it to do
something with it in in ten years ago
when i got in front of an audience and
talked about the application
nobody wanted to step outside that
philosophical theoretical intellectual
realm right because doing something
means you're gonna have to change
something about yourself yeah you're
gonna get uncomfortable right
and um i think we're in an age of
information
and in an age of information ignorance
is a choice and because of technology we
have access to so much content
and information creates awareness and
awareness is consciousness and you can't
have consciousness without energy there
they work together so there's an
energetic change i think that's taking
place in the world right now where
people are so informed
that old models old paradigms are
beginning to break down whether it's the
medical model or the religious model the
education model journalism uh
the economy you know uh
politics it's all beginning to uh
come to the surface because something
else has to come out and and i think
that one of the things that uh people
are realizing is that you don't have to
be a buddhist monk to do this or a nun
with 40 years of devotion you just got
to understand the formula and just like
any skill or anything you learn
you got to go from thinking to doing to
being you got to take knowledge you
create the experience and if you keep
doing it over and over again you start
getting a skill or you start getting
wise about how to do it and you you know
that you know how to do it if we teach a
person then how to trade that
frustration or that hatred for an
elevated emotion and they'll say yeah
but you know it was my ex's fault or i
got betrayed by my partner in business
yeah yeah yeah we know that okay so
let's take your partner in business or
take your ex let's duct tape them put
them in a cannon and shoot them to the
moon now what are you going to do sooner
or later you got to reckon with yourself
and change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude as an example yes the
person says well i can't feel gratitude
and i say absolutely you can because you
don't practice feeling it you practice
spending most of your time feeling
hatred and frustration so now it's going
to take a little time to cause that
heart of you to bloom or your heart of
yours to bloom once they're able to feel
even the smallest measure of gratitude
where they start feeling appreciation
thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something
when you're receiving something
when something has happened to you
or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened where it's happening to you so
the moment you open your heart and you
feel gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific destiny you've got to maintain
that modified state of mind and body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can
get ready
because something weird or unusual some
synchronicity some coincidence
some opportunity is going to land in
your lap and you didn't have to go and
get it yes it came to you now you're the
vortex of creation so if you say to me
well i was feeling gratitude but then
there was traffic or my co-worker sent
me a
nasty email then i would say oh my god
you mean you're allowing your
environment your outer environment to
control how you feel and think you're
back to the unconscious program that
you're the victim to your life you got
it but when you start producing those
outcomes in your life you're going to
pay attention to what you did inside of
you and you're going to believe more
that you're the creator of your life and
less of the victim of your life i think
that we define reality with our senses
and i think that is one of the biggest
delusions so the fundamental question is
can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet but you've thought about
enough times in your mind
that your brain is literally changed to
look like the event has already occurred
now the latest research in plasticity
says that's absolutely possible and can
you select a new possibility in the
quantum field and begin to emotionally
embrace that future every single day to
such a degree that your body as the
unconscious mind
the objective mind does not know the
difference between the experience in
your life that's creating the emotion
and the emotion that you're fabricating
by thought alone to the degree that you
begin to signal new genes and new ways
to change your body to look like the
experience has already happened now yes
the latest research in epigenetics says
it's absolutely possible now think about
this every day
installing the circuitry every day
conditioning the body into the emotion
of the future
that your body begins to change to look
like it's already happened now this is
where it gets fun
because now you no longer have to go
anywhere to get it
now it begins to come to you you become
the vortex or the magnet to your destiny
so then people who come out of their
meditation and they say well i just
focused on my wealth why isn't it there
well you're not that good if you're
asking why isn't it there you're back to
the old person again
stay in that state for an extended
period of time
as
an experiment as the scientist in your
life to keep your energy connected to
the to the dream of your future
and then
see what kind of effects begin to take
place without moving into impatience
without moving into frustration without
starting to analyze why it hasn't
happened or when that is the trap of
defining reality with your senses so you
have the thought of your future and you
don't see it then you experience
separation
but people who are practicing this work
they have the thought of their future
and they feel the emotion of their
future they're still connected to it
right so that takes practice and it's
just learning like hitting a golf ball
hitting a tennis ball dancing the salsa
you know crocheting whatever it is you
gotta you gotta start out staying real
conscious and learning then you get good
at it and it gets to be instrumental it
gets to be fun and that's that's what i
want for everybody that the act of
creation
should be a blissful playful ecstatic
loose
uh free process and um
and so
i love the idea of people taking time
out of their lives
uh to prove to themselves that if
they're defined by the vision of the
future
then they're not living by the memories
of the past and that's where the unknown
exists so many people
the unknown is a scary place
so they don't see that future
because they're used to seeing their
future with evidence with their senses
and you have to be able to get beyond
that and stay in the unknown stay in
that discomfort and then in that moment
to be begin to self-regulate like oh i'm
starting to feel a little anxiety oh i'm
starting to feel a little frustration
that's the defining moment where your
body's going back to the past because
emotions are a record of the past
or you go into routine again so you
catch yourself
it's a victory
and if you keep catching yourself those
victories add up
and it's not so much
about your wealth or your health or your
freedom or your new relationship
it's actually about who you become
we have a huge frontal lobe and it's 40
of our entire brain
and most people
uh when they have a thought they just
think that that's the truth and i think
one of my greatest
realizations in my own journey was
just because you have a thought it
doesn't necessarily mean it's true
so if you think 60 to 70 000 thoughts in
one day and we do and 90 of those
thoughts are the same thoughts as the
day before and you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny your life's not going to change
very much because the same thought leads
to the same choice the same choice leads
to the same behavior the same behavior
creates the same experience and the same
experience produces the same emotion and
so then
the act of becoming conscious of this
process to to begin to become more aware
of how you think how you act and how you
feel it's called metacognition and so
then
why is that important because the more
conscious
you become of those unconscious states
of mind and body
the less likely you're going to go
unconscious during the day and that
thought
is not going to slip by your awareness
unchecked
because you're
it means to know thyself the word
meditation means to become familiar with
so as you become familiar with the
thoughts the behaviors and the emotions
of the old self you're retiring that old
self as you fire and wire new thoughts
and condition the body into a new
emotional state if you do that enough
times it'll begin to become familiar to
you so
it's so important
just like a garden if you're planting a
garden you got to get rid of the weeds
you got to take the plants from the past
year and you got to pull them out the
rocks that sift to the top that are like
our emotional blocks they have to be
removed the soil has to be tenderized
and broken down we have to we have to
make room to plant a new garden so
primarily we learn the most about
ourselves and others when we're
uncomfortable because the moment you
move into that uncomfortable state
normally a program jumps in when that
program jumps in it's because a person
doesn't want to be in the present moment
and engage it consciously
so when you teach people how to do that
with a meditative process
it turns out that when they're in their
life
they're less likely to emotionally react
they're less likely to be so rigid and
believe the thoughts they were thinking
they're more aware of when they go
unconscious back into a habit and that
is what starts the process of change
and so we have to unlearn before we
relearn we have to break the habit of
the old self before we reinvent the new
self we have to prune synaptic
connections and sprout new connections
we have to
unfire and unwire and re-fire and rewire
we have to unmemorize emotions that are
stored in the body then recondition the
body to a new mind into a new motion
like deprogram and reprogram that's the
act and it's a two-step process the
majority of our thoughts and feelings
are connected to our sexuality
to our victimization our guilt our
suffering our shame our unworthiness our
self-doubt or our importance our control
our fear our anger our frustration our
hatred our judgment those are those are
the first three hormonal centers in the
body and and those first three centers
have everything to do with survival
and those centers are energy consumers
orgasm digestion
stress
is a lot of energy that that we're
drawing from our very vital life force
yes a resource of light and information
and we're turning it into chemistry and
we're literally robbing the body's
energy right so so then living like that
for the short term is okay because the
body can move back to homeostasis it can
restore itself but
when we're over doing that consistently
then there's no energy for growth and
repair there's because you're living
constantly in survival so
again you can eat all the right food you
can do all the right things but if
you're living in anxiety and fear and
you're viewing your world from the worst
case scenario that could possibly happen
because that's what you do in survival
there's no energy for growth and repair
there's no energy for healing so the
majority of our thoughts
are signaling certain circuits in the
brain that signal another part of the
brain limbic brain to make what's called
a neuropeptide neuropeptides or chemical
messengers that signal hormonal centers
so now you're taking thought
and you're storing it as energy in these
energy centers and and if you're living
in survival why would you open your
heart i mean it's just not a time to
open your heart i mean if you're getting
chased by t-rex
it's not a time to meditate it's not a
time to learn it's not a time to connect
it's not a time to communicate it's not
a time to sit down and go within it's
not a time to be vulnerable it's time to
run fight or hide and so is that why
we're this way i've never asked you this
before is this some
uh i don't i don't think you believe
this but i just want to understand is
this some sort of genetic disposition
that's been passed down to us since
we've been chased by t-rex i think so i
think survival has been very adaptive
yeah like because if you're being chased
by t-rex you don't run up to t-rex t-rex
and say oh cute little dinosaur let me
pet you that's not adaptive the fear is
adaptive you run from the unknown you
run from challenges right yes so if
you're living in survival there's better
chances of surviving
if you run from the unknown and by the
way when you're living in survival at
the infinite potentials in the quantum
field you'll select the worst case
scenario in your mind
and you'll begin to emotionally prepare
yourself for the worst case scenario
because you have better chances of
surviving there you go if you prepare
for the worst right so people spend
their whole life yes thinking about the
worst thing and emotionally embracing it
while you take a thought an emotion or
an image and an emotion you're branding
or conditioning your body into what
anxiety into fear so then you keep doing
that over and over again over and over
again your the body becomes the mind of
fear and
whether you think you can control it or
not you're gonna have a panic attack
and the panic attack is the body saying
you've conditioned me this way try as
you may with your conscious mind and
control it right you programmed it
subconsciously then you start worrying
about the next panic attack and it's
that very anticipation there we go it
keeps the person on the hamster wheel it
robs them of all of this energy as well
they're absolutely so so so they don't
believe
in possibility when they're living in
that state because in survival it's not
a time to create all the blood flow is
going to the hind brain and away from
the forebrain there's no there's there's
no physiology really for a person to
begin to create a new future so then so
think about it so then
70 of the time people in the world are
living anticipating the next moment
based on their past moment and so
they're laying reality down moment by
moment with the next known the next
predictable moment and so the hormones
of stress endorse the senses our senses
become heightened when we're under
stress
and we become materialists we narrow our
focus on the danger yes so then you're
focusing on matter you're focusing on
the material world and when you do that
you put all your attention the arousal
of the stress hormones puts all your
attention on your body if you're being
chased by t-rex you better be paying
attention we have research to show that
60 days of meditation
five days a week will lengthen your life
the telomeres the little shoestrings on
the end of your dna get longer that
means your biological age is changing
so we we have the evidence now
to show people what's possible we have
brain scans that
that are so outside of normal that when
neuroscientists see them they're blown
away because the amount of energy that's
in the brain during this transcendental
moment is uh
hundreds of times outside of normal wow
i mean you can't make your brain do that
something is happening to you and that
person's having a transcendental moment
and we now know that we can predict it
and we now know that we can induce it so
then there's the evidence there
then you take our community and you see
people with stage four cancer with
parkinson's disease with myasthenia
gravis with with lupus with ms with
brain injuries
with rare genetic disorders with vertigo
tinnitus
kidney failure all kinds of health
conditions
come to a week-long event
and then at the end of that event
they make significant strides in getting
beyond the emotions of the past now
think about this
the science says that the environment
signals the gene that's epigenetics
the end product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion so as long as
you're living by the same emotion every
single day you're signaling the same
gene in the same way and if that gene is
related to a survival emotion a stress
hormone then you're down regulating the
gene and you're creating disease so when
the person trades that emotion and
really breaks free from the chains of
their past
and now they're feeling an elevated
emotion
well now they're dialing down the gene
for ms
and they're up regulating the gene for
health and balance and so the person
will say to them where's the disease
well i'm not the same person
i'm not the and and the side effect
of that is a transformation in healing
so
the funny thing about it is the person
who has the healing is not talking about
the healing
whether it's blind people seeing deaf
people hearing hearing we have crazy
evidence now
what they're talking about is how
amazing they feel
because
they're refreshed they're they're they
got a new lease on life and so now we
have evidence
in our research
and that silence is the critic to show
that what's possible for people so then
if you're sitting in a meditation and
your body's thrown the kitchen sink at
you and saying ed you're a loser you're
never going to change this is too hard
why don't you quit and you're aware that
that's your body doing that and you say
to your body
we're going to sit here
and we're going to sit in this fire and
i'm going to keep applying the formula
and my your brain starts running to all
the emails you have to do and you become
aware of that and return back to the
present moment you tell the body it's no
longer the mind that you're the mind now
your will is getting greater than that
program and there's a liberation of
energy and every time you do that that's
a victory
and you teach every time you do that
that's a victory when your mind tells
the body i'm in charge when you say
you're when you you just want to get up
and you want to quit and you go
you know that's my body bring it back
okay and now you're now you're taming
the animal the body is the animal and
you're like a dog you sit
and if you keep doing this keep doing
this you're climbing on top and the body
finally acquiesces it finally says i'm
not going anywhere and then boom there's
this liberation of energy what's the
side effect
joy
person's heart just automatically opens
up and and
every time they do that those victories
add up there's no such thing as a bad
meditation there's only overcoming
yourself and when you sit in the fire
and you work with that people say to me
why do you meditate every morning i say
because if i can overcome myself in the
morning the rest of my day is easy it's
easy true because because that's what
it's about you master yourself you
master your life yes and so then all the
chatter in your head that you listen to
all day long that is called the default
mode network in the brain my research
shows
that shuts off not just shuts off during
the meditation it stays shut off for the
rest of the day so the critic in your
head that's telling you this will never
happen you don't have enough time all
right that there's no voice there so you
just have a clear
flow on where you're going and you trust
yourself more look i mean we're we're in
a convenience-based society i mean if
you if you lose your internet connection
or your cell phone doesn't do it it's
supposed to people get angry like yeah
that's 20 seconds right so here you are
creating something out of nothing
and you don't have the patience well
that has to come out because
a very very masterful person
who is abundant
had to own
impatience so then never make it be
about the end result make it be about
effort
every day you're overcoming every day
you're out of the bleachers and you're
on the field and you're giving it your
all and you're practicing keeping your
energy up greater than your habits in
your body or the emotional conditioning
of your body greater than any
circumstance in your environment and
sustaining it for an extended period of
time and all of a sudden
when you're connected to the energy of
your future
and you know what that feels like yeah
you will know the moment you return back
to the energy of your past and if you
tell me it's because of your boss or
your co-worker your ex i'm going to say
ah you're back to the unconscious
program that you're the victim of your
life right so then so then it takes some
unlearning and the unlearning process is
the most important process because once
you do that
you're clearing out room for the next
creation to be easier and the next one
will be easier because you're starting
to understand the formula a little
better and you start saying i'm not
going to take that personally or i'm not
going to react or i'm not going to go
back to that person again i'm just going
to self-regulate again yeah you only
need a few experiences to know that this
is the truth and then you start making
start managing your attention you manage
your energy a lot better and i think
that i i always say i don't care that
you fall off the horse i just care when
you get back on right because some
people fall off and then they have to go
into guilt and analysis and and they
take weeks and well you could have just
said i fell off let me just get back on
and keep going the stronger the emotion
you feel from some event in your life be
it a betrayal or a trauma or whatever
yes the more altered you feel inside of
you the more you pay attention to the
cause outside of you so the brain takes
a snapshot
it freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory
so we create long-term memories from
strong emotional events okay so is that
true i just want to understand the maybe
the larger the event in terms of its
emotion to you the stronger of a hold it
has over you yeah well the more it's
embossed in your biology so some certain
people have a strong experience in their
life
and it catches all of the brain's
attention so now they think
neurologically within the circuits of
the past experience and they feel
chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event
and you keep that refractory period of
chemicals going on for extended periods
of time so that the event produces a
chemical change and the body needs to
return back to homeostasis or balance
but if it can't then the elongation of
that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the mood so you say ed what's
wrong with you i'm in a mood why are you
in a mood well this thing happened to me
five days ago and i'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so that now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry i don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago i'm
having one long emotional reaction i'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves
by living in the past and so then you
say to them well tell me the story now
the latest research on memory says that
50
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have wow just to reaffirm that they
can't change right
so then what's the significance of this
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy period yes so then
the stronger the emotion that you have
to some problem or condition or person
in your life the more you're paying
attention to them so they captured your
attention so you're giving your power
away
to that person right because they're
capturing your attention so then there's
an energetic connection to every person
everything everything in your past
present reality has your energy
connected to it so now
this is the significance when a person
really decides to be defined by a vision
of the future instead of the memory of
the past the hardest part about it is
all of a sudden becoming conscious and
not making the same unconscious choice
so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lowered the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back three
types of stress physical chemical and
emotional physical stress trauma
accidents injuries false
chemical stress toxins pollutants heavy
metals blood sugar levels viruses
bacterias mold and then there's
emotional stress which has everything to
do with raising kids and
and second mortgages and single
parenting and time and and all of those
different elements knock the brain and
body out of balance and the emotional
component has always been the
challenging one for most people because
you could be in a constant state of fear
and consciously or unconsciously
it doesn't matter the food you eat it
won't matter the type of exercise you do
if you're living in fear the body is not
in any state for growth and repair so we
have to face this one important element
and this is a time now if you're sitting
down and you start thinking about
some future worst case scenario that
you're conjuring up in your mind
and you begin to feel the emotion of
that event
your body doesn't know the difference
between the event that's taking place in
your world outer world and what you're
creating by emotion or thought alone
so most people then
they're they're constantly reaffirming
their emotional states so when it comes
time
to give up that emotion
they can say i really want to do it but
really the body is stronger than the
mind because it's been conditioned that
way so
the servant now has become the master
and the person all of a sudden once they
step into that unknown they'd rather
feel guilt in suffering because at least
they can predict it being the unknown
is a scary place for most people because
the unknown is uncertain people say to
me well i can't predict my future
i'm in the unknown and i always say the
best way to predict your future is to
create it not from the known but from
the unknown what thoughts do you want to
fire and wire in your brain
what behaviors do you want to
demonstrate in one day the act of
rehearsing them mentally closing your
eyes and rehearsing the action
they're rehearsing the reaction of what
you want or
the action of what you want by closing
your eyes and mentally rehearsing some
action
if you're truly present the brain does
not know the difference between what
you're imaging and what you're
experiencing in 3d world
so then you begin to install the
neurological hardware in your brain to
look like the event has already occurred
now your brain is no longer a record of
the past now it's a map to the future
and if you keep doing it priming it that
way the hardware becomes a software
program and who knows you just may start
acting like a happy person i'm not the
type of guy who sits in my house
meditating 24 hours a day and expect
things to come to me i'm a pragmatist
i'm a practical person i'm going to take
value and information i'm going to apply
it and see if i can gain more value from
it so the message is not to sit and
meditate and just receive universal love
and do nothing else
because
my message is to not disengage in life
but to fully engage in life that's my
message toning world is all about the
predictable it's all about predicting
the future but the quantum model of
reality is is about causing an effect
the moment you start feeling abundant
and worthy you are generating wealth the
moment you're empowered and feel it
you're beginning to step towards your
success
the moment you start feeling whole
your healing begins and when you love
yourself and you love all of life you'll
create an equal and now you're causing
an effect
and i think that's the the difference
between living as a victim
in your world saying i am this way
because of this person or that thing or
this experience they made me think and
feel this way
when you switch that around you become a
creator of your world and you start
saying my thinking and my feeling is
changing an outcome in my life and now
that's a whole different game and we
start believing more that we're creators
of reality so
how do we then go from that like
mechanistically
to begin this visualization process of
something that's empowering it's me in a
different state it's my future self is
it meditation is
what does that look like if you're not
being defined by a vision of the future
then you're left with the old memories
of the past and you will be predictable
in your life
and if you wake up in the morning and
you're not being defined by a vision in
the future as you see the same people
and you go to the same places and you do
the exact same thing at the exact same
time
it's no longer that your personality is
creating your personal reality now your
personal reality is affecting or
creating your personality your
environment is really controlling how
you think and feel unconsciously because
every person everything every place
every experience has a neurological
network in your brain
every experience that you have with
every person produces an emotion so some
people will use their boss to reaffirm
their addiction to judgment they'll use
their enemy to reaffirm their addiction
to hatred they'll use their friends to
reaffirm their addiction to suffering so
now they need the outer world to feel
something
so
to change then
is to be greater than your environment
to be greater than the conditions in
your world in the environment is that
seductive
so then
why is meditation the tool well
let's sit down let's close our eyes
let's disconnect
from your outer environment so if you're
seeing less things there's less
stimulation going to your brain if
you're playing soft music or you have
ear plugs in less sensory information
coming to your brain so you're
disconnecting from your environment if
you can sit your body down
and tell it to stay like an animal stay
right here i'm gonna feed you when we're
done you can get up and check your
emails you can do all your texts but
right now
you're going to sit there and obey me
so then
when you do that properly and you're not
eating anything or smelling anything or
tasting anything you're not up
experiencing and feeling anything
you would have to agree with me that
you're being defined by a thought right
so when the body wants to go back to its
emotional past
and you become aware that your attention
is on that emotion and where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy you're siphoning your energy out
of the present moment into the past and
you become aware of that
and you settle your body back down in
the present moment because it's saying
well it's 8 o'clock you normally get
upset because you're in traffic around
this time and here you are sitting and
we're used to feeling anger and you're
off schedule oh it's 11 o'clock and
usually check your emails and judge
everybody well the body's looking for
that that predictable chemical state
every time you become aware that you're
doing that and your body is craving
those emotions
and you settle it back down into the
present moment you're telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and now your will
is getting greater than the program and
if you keep doing this over and over
again over and over again over and over
again just like training a stallion
or a dog it's just gonna say
i'm gonna sit and the moment that
happens when the body's no longer the
mind when it finally surrenders
there's a liberation of energy
we go from particle to wave from matter
to energy and we free ourselves from the
chains of those emotions that keep us in
the in the familiar past and we've seen
this
thousands of times in fact we can
actually predict it now on a brain scan
when i'm going through change in my life
or i have a specific outcome that i want
to create i love to get up early in the
morning that's my time i'm a 4 30 in the
morning guy because
that's my time the rest of the day i'm
serving but
i love getting up early and changing and
working and having some time to myself
and i believe that when i invest in
myself i invest in my future
and that time in my in my morning nobody
bothers me because that's my time
and because of brain waves and brain
chemistry
the door between the conscious mind and
the subconscious mind is more open
and so if i get up early and i'm kind of
between theta and alpha i don't have to
work as hard i'm not thinking i just
kind of relax into the moment
in the evening i always ask myself how
did i do
how was one lifetime in one day where
did i fall from grace what happened
and so
then when i look at seeing how i reacted
to someone or something or i made the
choice that i could have made a better
choice i naturally and we all do this
begin to think well if the same
situation happened again how would i do
it differently
and that's the act of beginning to come
up with a new plan
the act of rehearsing it in your mind
begins to install the circuits in your
brain priming your brain so that when
the next experience happens you could
modify your behavior to do a better job
in life that's called plasticity
so
it doesn't matter for me what meditation
i do any longer i like to just get up in
a new state of being i have people say
to me hey um
i miss my meditation today like i'm
supposed to go like this or something
and i say to them
eyes open our eyes closed
you know my eyes open our eyes closed
you know when you're passionate about
something you know when people can't get
up in the morning and they can't get out
of bed i'm going to tell you why
because they can predict the feeling of
everything that's going to happen in
their life and their bodies resigned to
the familiar it says another mundane day
but remember when you were a kid and you
were going on a field trip
what happened then
you were up and dressed and ready to go
before your parents were up you know why
because you knew something unexpected
was going to happen that's how we should
live our lives waking up with the
understanding to expect the unexpected
and something unusual should happen in
our life as a result of our efforts and
it's just those beginning moments where
it begins to happen that we begin to
prove to ourselves how powerful we
really are so take time in the morning
in the evening and the rest of the day
check in with yourself at certain times
to see if you're still in that energy
and if you're not excuse yourself for a
second raise your energy and step back
into your life if you keep doing that
over and over again you'll become less
frustrated less impatient less
judgmental it'll just become something
of the past and you'll be someone else
the hardest part about change is not
making the same choice as you did the
day before
and the moment you decide to no longer
think the same way
make the same choice
act the same way
create the same experience or live by
the same emotion it's going to feel
uncomfortable it's going to feel
unfamiliar there is going to be a
certain amount of uncertainty and
unpredictability
and the moment you feel uncomfortable
you just stepped into the river of
change
now most people the moment they feel
uncomfortable they return back to the
familiar state of the mind and body they
start thinking the same way acting the
same way feeling the same way and they
say this feels right
no in fact that feels familiar
now going from the old self to the new
self
is the neurological
is the chemical is the biological is the
hormonal and even genetic death of the
old self
that void that place of uncertainty that
unknown
is the perfect place to create him and
if you and i can become comfortable in
that unknown and begin to decide who we
do want to be
in other words many people say when
they're in that unknown i can't predict
my future
this doesn't feel right
well the best way to predict your future
is to create it not in the known but in
the unknown
so what if you said now
what thoughts do i want to fire and wire
in my brain
what behaviors do i want to demonstrate
and if you were to close your eyes and
begin to think about how you were going
to act
the mere act of mentally rehearsing who
you're going to be
begins to install the neurological
circuits in your brain
to look like the experience has already
occurred now what that means is the
brain is primed in its circuitry to no
longer be living in the past
but now living in the future we have
people that have been abused we have
people that have been traumatized that
have been um assaulted we have people
that have had very very difficult
difficult pasts and have you ever heard
me say to to
revisit the event
have you ever heard me say that
never do we need to revisit the event
because once you do you open the box
but what we want to do is overcome the
emotion because that's just what's
lasting from the event living in guilt
or grief or shame or unworthiness
someone tell me they lost a loved one
the other day and i said well okay how
long you been grieving oh about a year
really okay well suppose it was you that
left and you were looking at the person
you loved moping around for a year what
would you say to them after a year if
you truly love them get over it and have
a happy life i'm doing great
you should make yourself happy you
really love me
live a happy life that would be the
greatest testament of love for each
other
because if you're suffering then i go
you know you're making this hard on me
so then we always have to update our
versions
about reality because it's the only way
that we adapt
don't believe everything you've read or
heard it just may not be the truth
there's always a greater truth that you
and i can begin to investigate
surely someone in eternity has had
similar problems you and i and have
gotten beyond it yes or no so study that
person
you want to be wealthy
study wealthy people
don't just have some panacea that you're
just going to get wealthy
read about wealthy people and find out
that they lost everything and failed
miserably 20 50 times
but what they had as a
characteristic equality and their
personality is they were persistent and
they kept changing and they kept
forgiving and letting go of the past and
kept going
and sooner or later they ran into it and
when they had all the money they wanted
it was never about the money it was just
about that they could prove to
themselves that they can do it
and you and i are no different than that
but if you can't create a future
because of some emotion that keeps you
in the past you're going to have to
square off with that emotion and when
you sit down and your body has all those
physical sensations and it's getting
vigilant and it wants to get up and it
wants to move
and you're just going wow
and you're settling it down and you're
working with it
you gotta agree with me
that something greater in you
is climbing out of that body something
greater in you is awakening
and when you're able to overcome those
emotions truly break the addiction
don't you know that you'll return back
to your life and face the person that
betrayed you
and you will see a part of yourself that
you used to be that you no longer are
and you're not going to have anything
else but love for them in fact you're
going to have compassion for them
because you're going to realize how
stuck they are and you're liberated and
free if you think about this your senses
plug you into your external environment
everything you're seeing or smelling or
tasting or feeling or hearing all of
your five senses are affecting your
brain
so if you're waking up in the morning
and you're going through the same
routine behaviors as you did the day
before
and you're not in the process of being
defined by a vision of the future
then you're for the most part left with
the old hardware in your brain from the
past as a matter of fact your brain is
organized to reflect everything you know
from the past
so as people wake up and they begin to
pay attention to their body they start
to look around in their environment they
start to do typical things
it's the external environment that's
turning on different circuits in their
brain causing them to think equal to
their environment
and if you have the idea that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny as long as you're thinking equal
to your environment you keep creating
the same reality over and over again
so to change is to think greater than
your environment to think greater than
the circumstances in your world to think
greater than the conditions in your life
and i think every great person in
history understood this they were
defined by a vision that was much bigger
than that think of your autonomic
nervous system
as the automatic nervous system and i've
been saying for years that autonomic is
synonymous with automatic and it's that
part of our
systems a part of our nervous system
that functions behind the scenes of our
awareness and it regulates body
temperature and and hormones and blood
supply and blood sugar levels
uh in it and it happens without any uh
of our conscious mind
so
in the autonomic nervous system there
are two branches so one is the
sympathetic nervous system and its job
is for
protection
from threats and dangers in our outer
environment and think of the sympathetic
nervous system as the gas pedal and when
there's a danger to the gross anatomy of
the body
by something in our outer world that we
can perceive with our senses this system
is switched on automatically and once it
turns on
there's a host of physiological
functions
that begin to happen automatically
and when that occurs we're mobilizing
all of the body's energy
all of the body's resources
for that threat or that danger to deal
with it and and when it's switched on
we don't go half in we go all the way in
because we have to make sure that the
body is going to survive survive in a
threat or a danger in the outer
environment and and when there's a
release of all those adrenal hormones
we're tapping the body's resources
and we're mobilizing all of its energy
and pupils dilate salivary juices shut
off respiratory rate increases heart
rate increases
blood is sent to the extremities glucose
is mobilized the immune system dials up
and then it dials down and all of these
systems switching on and turning on is
to be able to allow the body to adapt to
some threat in the outer world and
uh that is the gas pedal and the
sympathetic nervous system or the
fight-or-flight nervous system uh causes
us to really do just a few things to run
from the danger
to fight
and stay or to freeze and hide
and those are the primary choices that
we have created in evolution
and so when the sympathetic nervous
system is switched on
and we as we've been saying for very
long for a very long time
uh
the short-term effect of the hormones of
stress the body can adapt and return
back to balance and it switches on
the other nervous system that branch of
the autonomic nervous system called the
parasympathetic nervous system
and think of that nervous system as the
break
or the clutch
this is where the body conserves energy
this is where utilizes nutrients and and
transports chemicals to cells and
metabolism goes up and and this is a
time for growth this is a time for
repair this is a time for restoration
and there's a delicate balance between
the sympathetic nervous system and the
parasympathetic nervous system
and so then when you're feeling
a constant fear
when you're feeling constant anger or
aggression when you're feeling constant
pain and suffering and you're living by
the hormones of stress
what was once very adaptive is now very
maladaptive because if stress is
knocking your brain and body out of
balance and the stress response is what
the body does to return it back to order
if we're living in constant fear then we
are tapping the body's vital resources
and there's no energy
for growth repair restoration there's no
energy for long-term building projects
70 of the time people live in stress and
living in stress is living in survival
now
all organisms in nature can tolerate
short-term stress you know a deer gets
chased
by a pack of coyotes when it outruns the
coyotes it goes back to grazing and the
event is over
and the definition of stress is when
your brain and body are knocked out of
balance out of homeostasis
the stress response is what the body
innately does to return itself back to
order so you're driving down the road
someone cuts you off you jam on the
brakes you may you give them the finger
and then you settle back down and the
event is over and boom now everything's
back back to normal
but what if it's not a predator that's
waiting for you
outside the cave but what if it's your
co-worker
sitting right next to you and all day
long you're turning on those chemicals
because they're pushing all your
emotional buttons
when you turn on the stress response
and you can't turn it off
now you're headed for disease because no
organism in nature can live in emergency
mode for that extended period of time
it's a scientific fact
that the hormones of stress down
regulate genes and create disease
long-term effects
human beings because of the size of the
neocortex we can turn on the stress
response just by thought alone we can
think about our problems and turn on
those chemicals
that means then
our thoughts
could make us sick
so if it's possible that our thoughts
could make us sick is it possible then
our thoughts can make us well the answer
is absolutely yes
so then what are the emotions that are
connected to survival let's name them
anger aggression hostility
hatred competition fear anxiety worry
pain suffering guilt shame unworthiness
envy jealousy those are all
created by the hormones of stress and
and psychology calls them normal human
states of consciousness i call those
altered states of consciousness
so then we tend to remember those
traumatic events more because in
survival you better be ready if it
happens again that's and and when
survival gene is switched on you could
have 10 really great things that happen
to you in your day
and you just have one bad thing that
happens and you cannot take your
attention off that bad that that unhappy
thing because the survival gene is
switched on many years ago after the dna
helix was discovered by watson crick
they said the blueprints of life you
know all diseases are created from genes
it turns out less than five percent more
like one percent of people on the planet
are born with a genetic condition like
type 1 diabetes or tay sachs disease or
sickle cell anemia the other 95 to 99
percent are created by lifestyle and by
choices you can take two identical twins
exact same genome one dies at 51 the
other one dies at 85.
same gene different environment
so
all of a sudden they said we lied
that was wrong it's not genes that
create disease it's the environment that
signals the gene that creates disease
well okay
but that's not the whole truth too
because you could have two people
working side by side in the same factory
one gets cancer after being exposed to a
carcinogenic for 25 years both working
for 25 years the other one has no cancer
at all
so there must be some internal order
that would cause one person to not get
it while another one does
so
is it possible then
if the environment signals the gene and
it does and the end product of an
experience in the environment is called
an emotion
can you signal the gene ahead of the
environment
by embracing an elevated emotion
we've done the research on this we
measured 7
500 different gene expressions in a
group of people
that came to an advanced event for four
days and we had them doing a seated
meditation a walking meditation a laying
down meditation a standing meditation
and at the end of four days just four
days
the common eight genes that were up
regulated two genes to suppress cancer
cells and tumor growth
two genes for neurogenesis the growth of
new neurons in response to novel
experiences and learning the gene that
signals stem cells to go to damaged
areas and repair them the gene for
oxidative stress
was upregulated we started seeing all
these genes that are very very healthy
to cause the body to flourish imagine if
people were doing that for three months
we also measured telomeres the little
shoestrings on the end of dna that tell
us our biological age we ask people
to do the work meditation five out of
seven days for 60 days
measure their telomeres that determine
their biological age 60 days later
74 of the people lengthen their
telomeres 40
significant change 20 a very remarkable
change that means that they got a little
bit of their life back if it lengthened
by 10 percent they got 10 of their life
back i think um
we're living in such an amazing time
right now i mean if you are not being
challenged in some way in your life
you're not alive
and all of this is an initiation
and i don't believe that you have to go
to any school of ancient wisdom perched
in the himalayas
or for information or training any
longer if you see your life
as the school as the initiation then you
can no longer be a victim to your life
you're going to have to meet the
challenges in your life from a greater
level of mind greater than the mind that
created it
and so
there have been plenty of peer-reviewed
articles on the power of peace gathering
projects lower crime that lower trauma
incidences of of uh
death and
economic growth it's all related to
what's happening right now for us
and it's not enough though for us to
just focus on peace
and expect the world to change because
in the peace gathering projects when the
event was over a lot of the
crime and violence returned back to its
ceiling level again
it's more important for us
not only to embody that piece and feel
it but then to demonstrate it
and when we begin to demonstrate it
i think we give people permission to do
the same
that means that we can't be preaching
peace and then be stuck in traffic and
you know flipping people off or you know
are arguing with your co-worker you
don't get to stand up for peace if you
have conflict in your life
so when we start i believe start
that self-contemplative process of
looking within
and instead of judging someone or
something look to see if there's an
aspect of ourselves within that person
or when that situation that we may need
to change and if we're all doing that at
the same time
something greater greater consciousness
is going to emerge
and so i believe that it should never be
about a person
it should be about principles
when we stand up for principles that
creates community because you could be
one belief or another belief but if
you're sharing the same principles with
your joy and freedom and cooperation and
connection that's what builds
communities
so then
everything in our world right now is
reminding us of separation
whether it's war whether it's violence
whether it's political deceit whether
it's prejudice all of those things cause
us to live by those stress hormones and
when we're living in that state of
survival we're not trusting and we
become more selfish
so then
starting our day asking ourselves what
would be the greatest expression of
myself i'd like to present to the world
and then making the choice to not get up
until we are that person
i think that begins to demonstrate
greatness
and when there is adversity and when
there are challenges in our life the
question of course becomes how do we
become supernatural
and that means we're going to have to do
what feels unnatural at first
when everybody else is in poverty and
lack
that's the time to give
when everybody else is in fear and
vigilance that's the time to show
courage
when people are angry and hating and
prejudice that's the time to show
compassion
people are competing to rush to get to
the top that's the time to change your
energy and draw the experience to you
and if you keep doing what's unnatural
over and over again sooner or later
you're going to become supernatural
there's another thing that you said that
i thought was really powerful about how
insights themselves are essentially
inert they don't do anything um what
what then do we do with an insight how
do we take a breakthrough moment and
make sure that it's not just a
breakthrough moment like i guarantee
people watching right now are having
like 100 aha moments
for sure that was definitely the case
for me as i was researching you and when
you said that i was like and that's the
danger that you have the aha and then
nothing yeah yeah and that's it's a it
is a danger because then people will
will shrink back into mediocracy and
they'll use the insight to excuse them
from taking a leap
they'll say yeah you know i have a
chemical imbalance in my brain my father
was
really overbearing he was a
perfectionist that's why i am the way i
am you know people they come up with
stuff
to to excuse themselves the insight is
actually giving them permission to stay
limited and it's it's a it's an amazing
idea because
they'll say to you
that they really want to get over their
anxiety
but let's okay let's take your
ex-husband let's put him in a
straitjacket let's duct tape him and
shoot him to the moon now what i mean
what are you going to do now you still
have to make those changes and so the
person's enemy dies or
something shifts in their life
and that person's gone they'll find
another person to hate this is just how
we function as human beings we just
slide another uh reason to feel those
emotions so
i think i think when people start to
understand this you know i think
knowledge is power
but knowledge about yourself is
self-empowerment crossing that river of
change from the old self to the new self
there's a neurological a biological
chemical hormonal a genetic death of the
old self but if you teach people there's
something on the other side they won't
give up on themselves they'll keep going
so there's enough evidence to encourage
people and you can't tell me you're too
old to do this work you can't tell me
you're too sick to do this work you
can't tell me you had a turbulent past
or or that you're too overweight or too
underweight or too out of shape or
you can't even tell me that you've never
meditated before in fact some of our
greatest
scans are people who just have never
meditated before that are not trying to
do anything they just follow
instructions so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible
and they go all in not fifty percent in
not sixty percent and we do a week-long
event we got a thousand people or
fifteen 1500 people and they are all in
and that when they start getting beyond
themselves that first day or second day
once they start getting beyond
themselves
and that magic starts to happen then i
have no idea i can't predict
what's going to happen next and it's
usually pretty pretty exciting you speak
about the
neurophysiology of forgiveness
sure
think about
frozen circuits
frozen circuits or hardwired circuits
the more profound the insult
to the person
that is connected to a strong emotion
the more the brain freezes circuitry
the more we think about the experience
the more we fire and wire the circuits
in our brain yes or no
and the more we remember the event the
more we produce the emotions that are
associated with it and we're
conditioning the brain and body further
into the past yes or no yes and it you
keep doing it enough times it's no
longer conscious that you're holding a
grudge
it's no longer conscious
that
you're stuck
it's now you're seeing everybody through
the lens of that experience and
everybody's a betrayer
everybody can't be trusted
everybody
is that same person you're you're
overlaying
the memory of re of your experience into
reality
you're not seeing it the way it is
you're seeing that person wearing the
mask of the last person
that's the lens that we're perceiving
reality are you with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception
triggers the emotion in the network and
you're back in your past and you're
acting like you were when it happened
are you with me still
and so then the person says i'm not that
person you say oh no i know i just had
this event in my past and i'm sorry
and then it's excusable but then here it
happens again
and there's nothing wrong with this
we all do it
it's just how do we overcome it
so then
you're sitting
and doing the work
and you're you're moving energy up those
centers
you're releasing
the life force into your brain
you are
blessing those centers and taking a
scoop and moving it all the way up and
releasing it all the way up into the
field you're opening the channel
your unfolding is nobody no one no thing
nowhere in no time and the identity and
the personality is gone which energy's
going to move scots it was going to
follow the path
you're opening your heart once it gets
to your heart it's going to make its way
all the way up and when you feel love
and compassion
when you feel true true kindness and
care it's hard to hold a grudge
are you with me still yes
so then from a
quantum physics point of view
you have that person always in the back
of your mind right you have the event
and the memory rolling around back there
because the very thing that you don't
want to have happen you're already
preparing for emotionally
are you with me still so then from a
quantum perspective you are actually
as a creator of reality
holding yourself hostage
because of that person
and you were holding them hostage
because of that experience
and you have an energetic bond that's
connecting you to them
and you're sharing the same energy
and so then you're using each other to
reaffirm whatever that
energetic agreement is are you with me
still
so then
when you forgive someone
it's because there's been a strong
change
in your emotional state
because the emotion is what's keeping
you energetically bound to them or to
more than one person
and so then once you start
lowering the volume to that emotion and
the body starts liberating energy and
you're calling your energy back to you
because the lower the volume of the
emotion the less you're going to pay
attention to that person there comes a
moment where there's a snap
there's a release the energy is broken
and once it's broken now all of a sudden
you free yourself
and you free them
and
this has happened to me in my life
the people show up 10 years later
completely changed and so
humble and so asking for forgiveness
just because
they had transformed and and i let them
go
so then
forgiveness
from a quantum perspective and a
neurophysiological perspective is just
taking your attention off them
that's all it is
and when you start getting happy with
yourself
and you start feeling those elevated
emotions because you're striving for
that you wouldn't trade this
for the grudge you were holding because
this feels too good are you with me
still now
once that heart opens up
and you start having energy in the
center and it's releasing
thirteen hundred to fourteen hundred
different chemicals that begin to
restore and regenerate the body the
bodies start getting a lift of energy
once it makes it's here now you're going
to see that track sending energy to the
brain the heart acts as an amplifier to
boost the brain
are you with me still
so then once the energy starts making
its way into the brain once the heart
starts to open we've measured this with
our students they have oxytocin levels
rise
once you start feeling oxytocin when you
feel more loved then you feel the grudge
so then you think
why would i want to give this up for
that person
that's called forgiveness
you don't have to try to do it
it just is a side effect of your
personal transformation
and oxytocin then
when it's released rushes right into the
amygdala the survival center of the
brain and the research is outstanding
and the first thing it does is it fits
in the same receptor sites
as fear and it lowers the volume to fear
and anxiety it shuts the lights out for
aggression and anger and hostility and
it cools the circuits off for suffering
and pain and the only thing you can feel
is a love for life and that's when
you're free now the practice
of forgiveness
matter to matter you can do it but it
takes a long time and a lot of work
and then you forgive and then you're
like i don't want to forgive him yet
[Music]
halfway forgive him and just never
really authentic forgiveness
do you understand
and you know there was a woman that came
to our work
and
she was raped by four men
when she was a teenager
and it was abusive
and
she had severe
severe night terrors
severe
anxiety and panic attacks she had cyclic
mood problems she had been to every
single doctor every single healer every
single alternative practitioner nothing
changed it
she came to our event
in
in
tacoma washington
and she hit that point where she became
everybody everyone everything everywhere
every time every place she became the
oneness
and that frequency had a message for her
and it said
and she was an incredible bliss when
this happened
i sent four angels disguised as rapists
for this moment
and that was the end of her terrors
that was the end of her night she
couldn't have a relationship she
couldn't she could not live with anybody
she was she was isolated
one moment the divine stepped in
and gave her the signal that was
carrying a very specific message and she
got the download not just that
not just the thought
she got the energy moved right through
her body and she saw the whole thing
and that moment
is what she was waiting for that's what
the soul was waiting for
now she's healed she's healthy she's
happy and she's on with a new life she's
born again my mother would love this
she's born again in the same life
reborn in the same life didn't pass
through a birth canal for it
she just was born again
in the same life she got a new lease in
one instant
that energy was carrying a message
and it made its way all the way into the
body and the bliss and the joy and the
gratitude and the love that she felt
and the message that was carried with
made total sense to her
she's free one instant
to me that's true forgiveness
that's the divine having its way with
you because most people are waiting for
their life the change yeah so they can
feel gratitude to feel abundance to feel
whole you know that's the old model of
cause and effect you know so if you're
living with emptiness you're living with
lack you're living with pain
most people have been conditioned that
something out there has to take away
this emptiness or feeling inside of them
but
if you believe that you're creating your
life
and you're living by lack well lack is
going to create abundance right so
so then it makes sense then that you
don't really actually
create wealth you generate wealth you
generate abundance so the moment you
start teaching your body emotionally
what that future is going to feel like
before it's made manifest well your body
is the unconscious mind believes it's
living in that future in the present
moment now it's a scientific fact that
it's the environment that signals the
gene okay
the end product from an experience in
the environment is an emotion
so when you begin to embrace an elevated
emotion you're beginning to signal the
gene ahead of the environment what's the
importance of that well genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and the function of
your body and the expression of proteins
is the expression of life so by you
creating an elevated emotion and
teaching your body what that future will
feel like before it's made manifest your
body's starting to live in that future
reality in the present moment now here's
the key
if you were able to become familiar with
gratitude become familiar with wholeness
become familiar with abundance to become
familiar with freedom and you're able to
generate those chemicals every single
day
more than likely you would be walking
around feeling like your future has
already happened then you would no
longer be looking for it to happen you
would already feel like it has happened
now what is the importance of that well
you're literally becoming somebody else
so you're leaving your lack you're
leaving your guilt you're leaving your
emptiness behind your personality
literally ad is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that
you begin to objectify your subjective
self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back to thought a new thought should
lead to a new choice a new choice should
lead to a new behavior a new behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
and that new emotion is teaching your
body chemically to understand what your
mind is intellectually understood now
your body is embodying the truth i
believe in human possibility human
potential and i think that one of our
biggest
limiting beliefs is the belief have how
limited we really are
and so my interest is to give people
the science to begin to understand how
powerful they really are and i think
that science really is the language that
does that really well and and the new
sciences like quantum physics and
neuroplasticity neuroscience
neuroendocrinology you know
psychoneuroimmunology the mind-body
connection epigenetics all of those
sciences point the finger at
possibilities so i want to create a
language for people
from a philosophical or theoretical
standpoint for them to begin to
understand what's possible
but then i want to be able to have those
people begin to wire that information in
their brain completely because learning
is making new connections right in the
brain
but remembering is maintaining and
sustaining those connections and it's so
much easier
to lose our vision than to remember it
right so then we have to begin to
hardwire the brain or install the
neurological hardware
in preparation for an experience so the
more people understand what they're
doing and why
then the how gets easier so i want to
then set up the conditions in an
environment in a in a in a workshop
where people can begin to
apply or personalize what they learn so
that they can have an experience an
experience then further enriches the
brain but the prize of an experience is
an emotion and once you start feeling
unlimited once you start feeling
abundant once you start feeling worthy
now you're teaching your body chemically
to understand what your mind is
intellectually understood so knowledge
is for the mind and experiences for the
body and people begin to embody the
truth of that philosophy now if they can
repeat it over and over again
it'll become innate in them and become
natural second nature will become easier
they begin to master that philosophy so
i want people to begin to understand
that
thoughts are very powerful feelings
drive our thoughts
and that they can begin to create a
better life for themselves once they
understand some of these principles we
have research to show that 60 days of
meditation
five days a week will lengthen your life
the telomeres the little shoestrings on
the end of your dna get longer that
means your biological age is changing
so we we have the evidence now
to show people what's possible we have
brain scans that that are so outside of
normal that when neuroscientists see
them they're blown away because the
amount of energy that's in the brain
during this transcendental moment is
uh
hundreds of times outside of normal wow
i mean you can't make your brain do that
something is happening to you and that
person's having a transcendental moment
and we now know that we can predict it
and we now that know that we can induce
it so then there's the evidence there in
order for you to to really begin to
explore the unknown aspect of yourself
you got to learn how to get beyond the
known aspect of yourself and if you keep
coming back to the known you're going to
miss out on the unknown so you would say
well i don't know anything in the
unknown of course it's the unknown and
if you try to control it there you're
back to the known if you try to predict
it you're back to the known so you got
to go through this trial and error of
just kind of refining your attention
refining your ability and and it's just
got to be something like playing tennis
or playing golf or doing martial arts or
working out or crocheting or stance in
the salsa you just got to keep going man
in the beginning it's tedious and then
when you start finding your groove like
our our community
they don't miss their morning
meditations yeah you know why because
the magic is happening and they know if
they miss it they're gonna they're gonna
cut off from the magic so they whether
they're tired whether they're hungover
whether they're what they're right
they're in right you know and if you if
you wake up in the morning
and you can't get your butt out of bed
you know what that means it just means
you can predict the feeling of
everything that's going to happen in
your life your body's resigned
so then so then you know when you went
on a school trip when you were a kid you
know you woke up before your parents
because you knew something new is going
to happen that's the body going wake up
wake up it's something unexpected is
going to happen what happened to us
christmas day
so why not
you know put in your put in your time
and then and then measure the effects of
you would cause i mean become a
scientist in your life and really start
to experiment with it okay let me change
my energy let me just write down four
thoughts
that like i can it's too hard it'll
start tomorrow this doesn't feel right
whatever it is it's be this person's
fault just write those down and say
these thoughts like gandalf on the
bridge yes you may not pass today this
is the end yes so then if you become
conscious of those thoughts now you're
the governor of your thoughts what what
what actions what behaviors do you want
to change do you complain you blame you
judge do you make excuses how do you
talk do you speak limited just pick four
things
that you're not going to do any longer
yeah
what emotions get you in trouble what
are the emotions that you're addicted to
too right that you're addicted to that
keep you returning back to your past if
you don't know
close your eyes for about 30 minutes and
just watch where your mind goes and
watch your feelings and just say okay
it's frustration it's unworthiness it's
self-doubt it's guilt it's frustration
it's shame
just
become conscious of those and just
review them in your mind so that you
don't go unconscious them in your waking
day we have a thousand reasons i have
more than a thousand reasons every day
to be unhappy with managing companies
and staff and people all that but but
then when you rise above that
and you choose just who you want to be
uh i think it makes a big impression
uh on your on your family first yourself
and your family and your friends and the
people you work with and then finally
our communities so i think that people
are starting to figure that out there
and and when they
imagine oxytocin levels in our student
body
the love hormone the love chemical 200
times outside of normal the latest
research on oxytocin a slight slight
elevation in oxytocin it's impossible to
hold a grudge now so then
what that means is you feel
so amazing
that why would you want to
hold the grudge against that person so
forgiveness then is not something that
you have to try to do to be spiritual
it's the side effect of saying
i don't want to give up this feeling for
you or anybody so i'm letting it go i'm
freeing you i'm freeing myself and my
goodness there's more liberation of
energy i call that the natural state of
being and we're knocking on that door
why
because as you begin to open your heart
to life again and you start trusting in
your future and trusting in yourself a
little bit more
and you start self-regulating with your
heart you do that properly and you lead
from that place from that level of
awareness your life will change
in dramatic ways and why is that
essential because when people start
doing that effectively
oxytocin signals nitric oxide nitric
oxide signals a chemical called
endothelial derived relaxing factor and
that causes the arteries in your heart
and lungs jay to literally swell just
like when you're
when your sexual organs are aroused and
blood flow moves into them male and
female that's a different consciousness
there's a different energy in there
imagine the same intensity moving into
your heart
that's what people are experiencing that
is a level of love
that's not like a love for your puppy
it's not like the love for your partner
this is transcendent of that this is the
most familiar unfamiliar feeling you
will ever have it'll be distant and at
the same time very close and you'll
start to see the hidden meaning behind
all things and now
when you walk in the presence of your
greatest betrayer
the person who threw you under the bus
whatever it is
when you walk in from this place
there will be no emotional reaction you
will just see that person for who they
are who you used to be now compassion
then is no longer something that you
have to try to do
it's the end product of doing the work
and i think that
mystics and saints and
masters of old understood this
so when they thought of that person
they didn't allow that thought to
produce a feeling or an energy that
would lower their energy
they understood that when they had the
thought of that person they saw their
limitation it wasn't hurting them it was
only hurting themselves now
i think that if the world was doing that
wow
thoughts
to me produce an electrical charge in
the quantum field
and feelings produce a magnetic charge
in the quantum field
thoughts wait thoughts produce a what an
electrical charge okay and feelings
produce a magnetic charge and how you
think and how you feel
broadcast an electromagnetic signature
that influences every single atom in
your life the thought sends the signal
out now think about this
and the feeling draws the event back so
you could have the intent that you want
wealth you want health you want success
that's your intent that's your thought
but if you're waiting for the experience
to happen to feel it then you're not
drawing the experience to you because
you're not feeling the emotion right so
then
teaching people once again how to
balance their thoughts and feelings
because you can you can enter that cycle
either place sometimes we do a
meditation
we start opening our heart we start
elevating the body's energy and then
those emotions can drive certain
thoughts of your future other times you
open your awareness you create brain
coherence you have the vision of your
future you begin to emotionally
experience it however you want to jump
on that cycle
and then sustain it because the longer
you're conscious of that energy the more
you're drawing your future to you so
then most people spend their lives right
they we live in this realm called
space-time three-dimensional reality and
you move your body through space in
three-dimensional reality it takes time
yeah so everything all your goals all
your dreams all your visions
you're gonna have to get your body up
and drag it through space every day to
pay off that you know that home that's
in your future right right
when you create from the field instead
of from matter
when there's a vibrational match between
your energy and some potential and your
thoughts and feelings are coherent now
you are going to begin to collapse time
and space or the experience is going to
be drawn to you now now you're the
vortex to your destiny and now you don't
have to go anywhere to get it because
you're not playing by the rules of
three-dimensional reality you're playing
by the rules of energy and the quantum
yeah i think uh you know if we
everything starts with a thought i mean
everything that you do in your life you
you have to have a thought before you
initiate an action right so
so if you believe that your thoughts
have something to do with your destiny
like any great leader in history
understands that
the first thing you have to do is you
have to decide are you going to be
defined by a vision of the future
or are you going to live by the memories
of the past so give you an example
most people wake up in the morning
and your brain is a record of the past
it's an artifact of everything you've
learned and experienced to this moment
right it's a it's a memory bank
so most people wake up in the morning
and they start thinking about their
problems and those problems are
connected to certain people and things
at certain times and places
and the moment they start start turning
on those circuits those memories are
actually causing them to think in the
past
every single one of those memories has
an emotion associated with them and
emotions are the end product of past
experiences
so then the moment they recall the event
or the they recall some problem in their
life they start feeling unhappy they
start feeling discouraged they start
feeling anxious now thoughts of the
language of the brain and feelings of
the language of the body and how you
think and how you feel creates your
state of being so we could say then
most people's entire state of being when
they start their day is in the familiar
past well if you live in the familiar
past then it makes sense you're going to
create the predictable future so what
happens for most people is they get
stuck in their biology so think about
this
your body is your unconscious mind it
doesn't know the difference between an
experience in your life that creates an
emotion and an emotion that you can
create by thought alone so if you're
living by the same emotion every single
day and those emotions are influencing
your thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel or feelings have become the means
of thinking you're thinking in the past
your lens of the future is going to be
colored by the past so you can't see
possibilities so most people like to
wait for crisis or disease or diagnosis
before they wake up enough to see well
the challenge is that biology tends to
be redundant so
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
and those thoughts be begin to fire
certain circuits in your brain the nerve
cells that fire together wire together
so all of a sudden you start getting
hardwired and those are the thoughts
that you can think the easiest at the
same time those thoughts produce
chemicals called emotions and the next
thing you know your body gets accustomed
to living by the same emotions and it
could be guilt it could be unhappiness
it could be pain but at least it's
familiar to you at least you can predict
it so some people would rather cling to
the familiar than take a chance in
possibility so
for most people then they say well
i don't really see how my thoughts have
anything to do with my destiny well
that's because 95 of those thoughts are
subconscious programs right so you're
not even conscious that you think those
thoughts so the first step to change
is starting to think about what you've
been thinking about and change it and
and then when you begin to observe those
thoughts you're no longer the program
you're the consciousness observing just
simply by being an observer of your
thoughts right so so though so most
people though when they when you do that
when you decide to really take a look
it's like lighting a match in a dark
place
so you feel uncomfortable so it's easier
to turn on your tv it's easier to
play with your cell phone to distract
yourself from those feelings well
when you understand that change really
requires becoming uncomfortable to a
certain degree and that's normal that
you're leaving the known and you're
stepping into the unknown
then it begs the question what thoughts
do you want to fire and wire in your
brain because your attention on those
thoughts begins to reorganize circuitry
re-mold the brain when you're feeling
gratitude and your heart is open you're
broadcasting energy into the field
frequency the frequency you lay the
intent of the thought of your health or
your wealth
that frequency can carry the thought of
your wealth it can carry the thought of
your health if you're suffering
you can't the suffering does not carry
that energy does not carry the thought
of your wealth it carries a different
set of thoughts so then so then we're
teaching people
how to self-regulate because if you're
going to believe in that future that
you're imagining with all of your heart
it better be open and activated and you
better know how to self-regulate and you
have to know
the moment you disconnect from the
energy of your future because of some
circumstance in your life and you lose
that feeling
if you're practicing it on a daily basis
with your eyes closed then the next
level is to be able to open your eyes
and do it right in the moment and be
able to self-regulate and change
the the frustration from some experience
in your life back to the energy of your
future now
that requires great awareness and great
effort but if you have a community of
people
that are practicing this on a daily
basis and they're connected to their
future because that's where their their
mind is
um they begin to want the future
more than the emotions of the past so
we've done enough measurements now lewis
to know that we can teach people how to
do that and we have evidence that people
can sustain it
for 45 minutes to an hour it's a skill
now they know that they know how to do
it so now they have brain coherence and
heart coherence well once the heart
begins to become orderly and coherent it
acts as an amplifier and it drives
energy to the brain so now the brain is
getting more energy once the heart is
open and then you're thinking different
set of thoughts and those thoughts
produce different chemicals for you to
feel more of that and here comes
uh nitric oxide from oxytocin and then
all of a sudden your heart literally
starts to swell it literally begins to
open up and there's more energy going
there and now you're coming from a
different level of mind you have to
really begin to
mentally rehearse
like so you ask yourself at the end of
your day i do this every day how'd i do
how'd i do today bro how'd you do did
you do good where'd you fall from grace
what what what was it
that caused you to go unconscious
for the rest of the day like what was
that moment now if you're a student
of life
you'll begin to contemplate well it was
that person that said that thing then i
reacted or this i got this email or
things didn't go my way and i started
feeling angry or frustrated or fearful
the next time that happens
how could i evolve my experience now you
may have to search for some answers
of the best model to build or you may
actually have a long contemplation and
start to go god the next time that
happens i think i'm going to do this or
i'm going to do that or i'm going to
plan my behaviors
and the act of closing your eyes
and rehearsing what you're going to do
begins to install the neurological
hardware in your brain to look like you
already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past now it's a
map to the future and if you keep
installing that hardware the hardware
will become a software program which
means you'll just start acting like a
happy person why there's no magic there
you install the circuitry so
that's more important
than the news right it's more important
than answering any email or any text
it's more important than talking about
your past or some dinner
if you can begin to just
think about how you're going to do it
differently
that's the building process
neurologically already so now you have
to get conscious in order to do that and
it takes some time it means you got to
shut your cell phone off you got to
close your door you got to take a break
from everything out there and begin to
practice and so
by experience then
you start noticing oh here it comes here
comes the frustration here comes the
fear
and now we've given people the tools to
be able to self-regulate to create brain
and heart coherence and so you see
people say excuse me one minute i'm just
gonna need a minute
it takes some breaths they get back in
they connect to the energy of their
future this is incidental compared to
where they're going so they don't
fall from grace they don't allow their
energy to drop and so
yeah in the beginning
it takes a lot because it takes a lot of
energy and awareness
to stay conscious and not go unconscious
but if you're persistent and you're
determined and you're sincere
you begin to figure it out you begin to
say
i am not going to give my power away to
that person or that circumstance when i
can use it to heal or to create a new
future and so people then
won't excuse themselves and say on a
hard day yesterday i had a fight with my
co-worker or my ex or and i don't feel
like doing the work well
that's the time to get back on the horse
yeah because because
it's the it's all of those times that we
self-correct
those are the most valuable moments to
us people who've had
profoundly transcendental experiences
where they
we say got lit up they connected and
their brain goes into very very high
coherent states and
super gamma patterns that are way
outside of normal and they have a
transcendental download or connection
that's mystical
they look back at their entire life
they don't want to change one thing in
their past
because it got them to that moment
that's the moment the past no longer
exists now by the same means
they look back at their past
and they see all those tough moments
where they overcame themselves and they
fall in love with that person they don't
look at the good meditations or the
things that went well they look they
know that it was those moments that got
him to this moment
and i think then
that's when they begin to understand
that that all of the hard work
all the effort
in who we become makes no one can take
that away from us so then once we arrive
at that level and we experience whatever
the dream is or whatever we create the
next thing is do it until you fully
enjoy it and then when it gets boring or
predictable let's go again let's do
something else yeah and our research
shows that when you get a community of
people together
and they begin to open their hearts and
they they have the intent for the
greatest good for people that they know
or people that they could focus on
that our research shows that you can
actually affect another person's
autonomic nervous system when you move
into hard coherence in a very non-local
way well what's the significance of that
well we have an amazing community
and our community is connected by these
elevated emotions those other emotions
of survival create separation but we we
work to open our hearts and to feel
connected we can begin to affect people
in a very non-local way
in other words everybody else's hearts
go into coherence at the exact same time
you by opening your heart
strengthen your connection to this
community you strengthen
the connection to the people that you
relate with in your lives when you move
into that state
you you begin to affect everybody else
every time we have a thought we make a
chemical and and if you have
uh an unlimited thought you will feel
unlimited and if you have a
self-depreciating thought you'll feel
unworthy and your brain instantaneously
fires circuits
that signal another part of the brain to
release peptides or chemical messengers
that signal hormonal centers
and when we get that arousal from the
thought that we think
those thoughts sometimes weaken the
response weakens the physical body so
it turns out that
the emotions that are created from the
thoughts are the signaling mechanisms of
the body thoughts of the language of the
brain and feelings are the language of
the body and how we think and how we
feel
creates our state of being
so it turns out that the thoughts based
in the stress hormones
based in survival those are the thoughts
that begin to push the genetic buttons
that create disease in other words
a person wakes up in the morning
and the brain is a record of the past
the first thing they do when they wake
up in the morning is they start thinking
about their problems
and those problems are memories that are
etched in the brain that are connected
to certain people certain objects uh
certain things at certain times and
places so if you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny the moment you think about your
problems you're thinking in the past
right now every one of those problems
has an emotion associated with them
because we've experienced them so the
moment you remember your problems
now you feel unhappy now you feel
anxious now you feel fear
so the moment we feel those emotions
it takes a thought and a feeling
a memory or an image an emotion
a stimulus and a response and we start
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past now the body
is so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion
and the emotion that person's
fabricating by thought alone the body's
believing it's in that environmental
condition
so if the environment signals the gene
and that's the truth
and the end product of an experiences in
the environment is an emotion
we're signaling the same genes and genes
make proteins and if you keep signaling
the same genes you start down regulating
the gene to make cheaper proteins and
the body begins to break down now that's
an unconscious process
so what goes along with that is the
moment the person feels that emotion of
unhappiness or whatever it is
the brain checks in with the body and
says yeah you're feeling pretty
miserable you're suffering and we tend
to generate more thoughts
equal to the feeling that we have
and so then we get caught in this loop
of thinking and feeling so if we can't
think
greater than how we feel
our feelings have become the means of
thinking
then we're thinking in the past i'm
starting to realize how conditioned we
are into believing how limited we are
and as you start peeling those layers
away and you break through those beliefs
those self-limiting thoughts and
emotions
on the other side of that is where the
miraculous happens so you got to be
willing to be in that place of
discomfort long enough to reorganize
order and begin to create more coherence
and then all of a sudden you get this
recalibration that goes on in the brain
and body and then the extent of that is
that the ultimate thing is you start to
see feedback in your life those
synchronicities those coincidences those
opportunities you're scratching your
head going
everything is falling into place yeah
i'm in the right place at the right
thing i think about just comes to me
because your energy is synchronized it's
look i mean
when you have coherence in the brain and
heart you have a laser of energy and it
could read information much better
you're living in stress and your brain
is shifting its attention from one
person to another problem to another
thing to another
place to go each one of those things
there's an assignment of neurological
networks in the brain so the arousal of
the stress hormones drives the brain
into this high frequency and you're
trying to control and predict everything
in your life and those your brain
circuits are firing like a like a
lightning storm in the clouds when your
brain's incoherent you're incoherent and
and you can't you don't have a signal
you're you don't have a wi-fi signal i'm
not connected to the field how could you
how could you connect to energy and
information if your signal hasn't become
orderly so that when people synchronize
their energy into coherence they can
synchronize to a possibility in the
future and the synchronicities that are
feedback from the environment are just a
reflection of your energy
and that's the universe saying
follow the breadcrumbs do it again
follow it again do it again and now all
of a sudden the person's not waking in
the morning like oh
i gotta meditate now to create my future
they're kind of going like i'm getting
out of bed because i don't want the
magic to end right they want to they
want to sustain that state so that
the old
reality that they've lived in begins to
transform into something new and because
there's no longer a vibrational match
with everyone and everything in their
past present reality there's a
vibrational match to their future and
now their future is starting to give
them signals what thoughts do you want
to fire in wire in your brain what kind
of
attention and intention
do you want a place so that that becomes
the loudest voice in your head and if
you keep practicing it the hardware
becomes a software program and it'll say
jay you can do anything jay
you live in no time and accomplish
everything jay you're unlimited you just
got to hang with it on the other side of
this is greatness whatever you want to
program in there you get the program in
there if you sat down and say how am i
going to be with my wife my husband my
partner how am i going to be with my
kids i'm going to be at work with my
co-workers how am i going to be in
traffic
and you close your eyes and you begin to
rehearse in your mind if you're truly
present the brain does not know the
difference between the real life
experience and what you're imagining
so now the brain goes from a record of
the past to a map to the future now
you're installing the hardware keep
practicing it it becomes automatic comes
easier now it's a software program you
may just start behaving differently now
i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the science says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you i
think that
in order for us to truly change we have
to get beyond ourselves and that is
one of the arts of transformation
and
with the moment we are completely in the
present moment we cannot be running a
program it turns out coincidentally
when we're truly in the present moment
all possibilities in the quantum field
exist in the eternal now
so when we're truly present and we take
our attention off our body off of people
in our lives off of things off of places
and even time that's the moment as i
said today we become pure consciousness
that's the moment now we are no longer
playing by the laws of newtonian physics
that's the moment we no longer have our
attention invested in this
three-dimensional reality and where we
place our attention is where we place
our energy
so then the moment we become nobody no
one no thing nowhere and no time that's
the moment we get beyond ourselves
it is that act of being in the present
moment that allows us to see new
possibilities that we could never see
from the place where we are stuck in our
own programs and personality
the act of doing that as bruce said is a
skill and it requires feedback and
feedback happens in a couple ways one
way you get feedback is to begin to
measure the changes you see in your life
another way is that you feel differently
another way is that the voice in your
head goes away that's telling you you
can it's too hard you'll never change
this process if it was easy
everybody would be doing it
and yet we are piercing a veil
where people are waking up and they're
beginning to take their power back
we already innately know how to do this
all we have to do is keep practicing
until we start seeing those wonderful
wonderful feedback mechanisms happening
in our life the moment you start seeing
those changes taking place in your life
you are going to pay attention to what
you did to cause it and the moment you
pay attention to the cause of that
action you're no longer thinking that
it's something out there that did it
you're beginning to realize it's what
you did inside of you to produce it
that's when we begin to take our power
back
if you want some incredible motivation
from john assaraf check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there are they gonna move me towards
what i want or away from what i want
okay so you you don't you don't try to
change anything just ask yourself you
recognize just become more aware